You can buy mass produced
skis from a large company
or you could choose to
purchase a handcrafted
said from a small independent.
It's a matter of
preference, much
like drinking beer
produced by a major brewery
versus a microbrewery.
In fact, many ski buying guides
call small independent brands
microbrews.
Handmade skis typically
feature exclusive designs
with high-end craftsmanship.
They're produced in
limited quantities
by small independent companies.
This maker builds
the core of the ski
from two types of wood, Colorado
aspen and Colorado pine.
They're harvested from trees
killed by pine beetles.
Workers glue together 8
to 10 pieces depending
on the width of the ski.
The pieces form
a laminated block
that's structurally stronger
than a solid piece of wood.
They clamp the block in
a press for two hours
while the glue dries.
After they remove the
block from the press,
they use a band saw
to cut off strips.
Each strip will be
the core of a ski.
One block typically
makes six ski cores.
Next, they shape the ski cores
with a router using a template
underneath the ski contour.
They apply a blowtorch to strips
of ultra high molecular weight
plastic to make it bondable.
Then they coat the plastic with
epoxy and adhere a strip of it
to each side of the ski core.
This forms a sturdy
side wall to protect
the core from side impact.
After the epoxy sets, they
saw six inches off the front
and back of the ski.
With a hand planer, they taper
the thickness of the ends.
Then they heat the sidewalls
again to prep them for bond.
But first, workers
glue a plastic core
called a tip spacer to the
front of the wood core.
This holds the parts
together during construction.
Then they use a hand crank dye
machine to dye cut the brand
name and logo into
a strip of ultra
high molecular weight plastic.
They die cut the
same letters in white
then place them in the
black cutout strip.
This is the ski's base.
Now they can begin
constructing the ski's.
They take a left and
right base and spread
epoxy over the entire surface.
They lay down a layer of
epoxy saturated fiberglass
and position the
ski core on top,
then they spread epoxy on
the core and tip spacers
as well as lay extra
fiberglass where
the bindings will be installed.
They position steel plates
for mounding the bindings,
then cover the entire ski with
another layer of fiberglass.
Finally, they add
a nylon top sheet
printed with a graphic design.
They cover the assembly with
a series of metal sheets
and silicon heating blankets,
then place everything
in a custom designed ski press.
When workers activate the
press, rubber bladders
inflate pressing the
wood into a ski shape.
35 minutes later, the skis
come out of the press.
A worker separates
them with a band saw.
Using a jigsaw, they
trim the tip and tail.
The saw leaves a
rough edge so workers
sand the entire perimeter.
Then they taper and
bevel the sidewall.
This gives the ski's a
better edge grip on snow.
The final step is
to peel off the film
that has been
protecting the nylon
top throughout construction.
These handmade skis come in
several different styles,
shapes, and sizes.
All they need now
are bindings, then
it's all downhill from here.